The hallucination inducing drug ‘ayahuasca’
has been used for centuries by tribes in South
America during spiritual ceremonies. But as
it becomes more mainstream for those seeking
optic and auditory hallucinations, what exactly
is it, and how does it affect your body and
brain?
Ayahuasca is actually a combination of the
leaves of one plant (Psychotria viridis) and
the vines of another (Banisteriopsis caapi)
- neither of which have any hallucinogenic
power on their own. But the leaves do contain
DMT (N,N-Dimethyltryptamine), which is structurally
similar to your neurotransmitter serotonin
and to the chemical found in magic mushrooms!
The problem is, your gut enzymes normally
deactivate DMT before it’s absorbed into
your bloodstream; and this is where the vines
come in. They inhibit your gut enzymes from
working properly, and allow DMT to travel
within your blood and eventually cross the
blood-brain barrier.
The effects of the drink usually hit around
half an hour after consumption, with hallucinations
peaking after one hour, and subsiding within
four to six hours. But these hallucinations
are reported to be different from drugs like
LSD and shrooms in that most people are fully
aware that they are visually hallucinating.
In addition, instead of ‘hearing voices’
the sounds heard are usually exacerbations
of the noises already occurring around them.
And unlike those who consume LSD or shrooms
from a ‘good trip’, many who drink ayahuasca
are seeking to reconcile with their thoughts
and emotions, as well as past and present
traumatic events. Afterwards, most feel more
at ease with their thoughts, and more accepting
of their present situation.
The Default Mode Network, is a distinct area
of the brain that if overactive is associated
with depression, anxiety and social phobia.
And fMRI brain scans show that ayahuasca causes
a significant decrease in activity within
the default mode network. This is usually
linked with a meditative state and explains
why for those seeking optic and auditory hallucinations,some
ayahuasca drinkers feel at peace with themselves,
and find a renewed sense of purpose after
a trip.
Additionally, DMT has been linked with proteins
that promote the maintenance of long-term
memory, neural plasticity and the regeneration
of new neurons. It can bind to specific receptors
found on mitochondria and endoplasmic reticula,
and may even have the potential to kill certain
cancerous cells. On top of this, alkaloids
from the vine have been shown to induce apoptosis
in mice melanoma cells and certain liver cancer
cells in humans. This is not to say that ayahuasca
is a replacement for radiation or chemotherapy,
but it may hold future possibilities for cancer
research. Interestingly, unlike other drugs
such as alcohol or cocaine, ayahuasca does
not seem to create a tolerance, so regular
drinkers aren’t required to drink more in
order to achieve the same effect experienced
the first time.
After consumption, drinkers usually suffer
violent retching, vomiting, and even diarrhea,
as the brew is extremely acidic, making an
upset stomach normal, even in experienced
drinkers. And there is a dark side of Ayahuasca
too - fatalities have been linked to its ingestion,
particularly among tourists, though the manner
of death is often undetermined. The increase
in popularity has also given rise to fake
shamans, unqualified to create the brew safely.
Ultimately, the data is currently too sparse
to seriously consider ayahuasca recreationally
and more clinical trials are required to conclude
whether ayahuasca is safe.
Special thanks to audible for supporting this
episode to give you a free 30 day trial at
audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to recommend
the book “Hallucinations” by Oliver Sacks
which takes an in-depth look into the myriad
of conditions that induce hallucinations,
and shows how common they actually are! You
can get a free 30 day trial at audible.com/asap
and choose from a massive selection! We love
them as they are great when you’re on the
go.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!